à 14 mois ahmadi a accouché par
césarienne dans un hôpital de saskatoon
mais voilà le médecin qui a pratiqué la
chirurgie a aussi pratiqué une dictature
des trompes sans son consentement et
sans même la visée elle milite depuis
des années pour que la stérilisation
forcée soit criminalisée oui créé
on ne peut pas changer les préjugés de
quiconque et raciste dit elle de ceux
qui croient avoir le droit de décider
qu'une femme autochtone métis inuits ou
racisées doit être stérilisés
ch.d
elle n'est pas seul à se battre des
recours judiciaires ont été intentés par
des femmes autochtones qui ont des
histoires semblables partout au pays au
québec contre l'hôpital de joliette en
saskatchewan contre l'hôpital royal
universitaire de saskatoon et au
manitoba contre l'hôpital de st boniface
se sont non ça ce sont nos grands mères
se sont même noguès ont été affectés par
sa des femmes qui témoignent que lors de
leur accouchement en plein travail ou
sous l'effet de la péridurale le médecin
leur a demandé de consentir à la
stérilisation ou encore qui ont pratiqué
l'intervention sans obtenir leur
consentement et commun on va garantir
que cette pratique n'arrivera plus
jamais
pour y mettre fin le comité sénatorial
des droits de la personne formule 13
recommandations
la première étant de faire de la
stérilisation forcée une infraction
criminelle et des doctrines challenge ce
sont les médecins qui seront visés par
cette effraction et la loi devra
comprendre un formulaire de consentement
détaillé dit la sénatrice yvonne boyer
le comité demande aussi que les femmes
soient dédommagés le processus devrait
guider par des survivantes bien sûr et
puis les sénatrices réclame des excuses
officielles du gouvernement enfin on
accepte que ça a été fait ici est que ça
arrive encore ici au canada
la militante retrouve un peu d'espoir
peut-être dit-elle qu'en 2022 on verra
en fait la stérilisation forcée être
criminalisées et l'ensemble des
recommandations être suivi
bien que le rapport s'adresse
principalement gouvernement fédéral les
sénatrices invite aussi les provinces et
les organismes professionnels du milieu
de la santé à prendre les moyens
nécessaires pour que cesse une fois pour
toutes la pratique de la stérilisation
forcée au pays ici valérie gamache radio
canada ottawa